have you ever woken up from the dream so  real that for a moment you can't  remember where you are this is a lot  like that 16 years that's more than a  third of my life leading up to this  moment right here  you found a discrepancy I found a  misrepresentation we should celebrate  let's go up so what do you do I'm an  attorney  why do you like a public defender told a  corporate faceless guy all the way  really  they're just wondering why I brought my  dad so he was going on the first okay  how long till his stuff is supposed to  kick in it's gonna hurt you like  [Music]  on the docking party movies phone right  now  the universe is trying to tell you some  of her pay attention  you still think you're on drugs  the universe knows what once  balance  fighting that just throw your life into  chaos  [Music]  you're almost there  this rain  [Music]  that's a twist  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you